[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans ça vous
regarde en direct ravi de vous retrouver
au sommaire ce soir la survie de la
gauche aux législatives après les
écologistes les communistes viennent de
signer un accord avec les insoumis mais
ça bloque toujours avec les socialistes
nous verrons pourquoi simple marchandage
électorale pour sauver les meubles
au programme comment dictée par jean luc
mélenchon on en débat dans un instant
avec nos invités notre grand témoin ce
soir s'est transformé le temps d'un
essai en médecin légiste il s'est
appliqué à disséquer les organes de la
gauche pour identifier les maladies qui
la ronde en trahissant l'idée de progrès
elle a tourné le dos à l'avenir c'est la
nappe émise cette trahison qui nous
propose dans son dernier livre
renaud dély est avec moi ce soir enfin
nous retrouverons 2 a franchi pour leur
parti pris ce soir fanny guinochet nous
proposent leur donnant ce de martin
hirsch pour sauver l'hôpital l'analyse
isabelle lasserre pour comprendre
l'offensive de la cour suprême
américaine pour remettre en cause le
droit à l'avortement et puis un nouveau
rendez vous quotidien avec l amont d'un
gab à des 577 météo complète de la
campagne des législatives
voilà pour le menu c'est parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue et vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'être au
rendez-vous bonsoir renaud dély c'est un
plaisir de vous retrouver sur ce plateau
journalistes éditorialistes politiques
tous les matins sur france info pour les
informer notamment et puis le samedi sur
arte aux manettes du magazine 28 minutes
vous signez aux édition de
l'observatoire cette anatomie d'une
trahison la gauche contre le progrès
cette année c'est très stimulant sans
appel aussi il faut bien le dire sur les
différents renoncement trahison le moins
très forces de la gauche qui l'ont mené
dites-vous jusqu'à la mort clinique on
va en parler dans la deuxième partie de
l'émission je vois que vous faites un
peu la moue dubitative non non non non
et non vous dessinez la gauche c'est
pour ça que ça devrait vous faire une
mauvaise ambiance à mourir dans le coma
voilà la mort clinique ou complètement
constaté salah gosh contre eux pour
électorale on peut en sortir du coma
l'espoir est permis on va commencer avec
l'actualité qui interroge d'ailleurs
d'une certaine façon votre thèse elle
nous mène tout droit devant le siège
parisien des insoumis où les
négociations avec les socialistes ces
terroristes il reste des points qui sont
des points de blocage pour l'instant à
la fois sur le fond mais essentiellement
sur la question des circonscriptions
honnêtement le parti socialiste peine à
intégrer un peu le résultat qui a été le
sien à l'élection présidentielle voilà
coup de pression à la mi journée ou
constat d'échec on va le savoir on est
en direct peut-être qu'on aura une fumée
blanche tout à l'heure à l'issue de ce
long conclave au siège des insoumis le
pc en revanche a topé avec l efi bonsoir
alexis corbière et bienvenue sur ce
plateau député la france insoumis de
seine saint denis porte parole de jean
luc mélenchon bonsoir ian brossât et
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes élu
communiste de paris et vous avez soutenu
bien évidemment fait d'un roussel
pendant la campagne présidentielle
adrien broche de l'institut de sondages
viavoice va nous rejoindre dans un
instant il vient de publier une note à
la fondation jean jaurès sur la gauche
on verra si elle a encore un espace ou
pas mais d'abord pour nous planter le
décor bon camarade et complice stéphane
blakowski
où en sont ces négociations tiens tiens
si j'ai bien compris foetale fille
[Musique]
mon frère stéphane si j'ai bien compris
que ça peut changer d'une seconde à
l'autre ce téléphone là peut sonner pays
a remarqué bientôt accords conclus mais
pour l'instant les socialistes n'ont pas
signé de ralliement à jean luc mélenchon
alors pourtant ce matin sont est cadré
1,4 nas commence à devenir un peu
impatients quand même pas fou le
comprendre peut-être que le discussions
sont jamais aussi longue voyez chez les
insoumis jean luc mélenchon dit un truc
de monde est d'accord voilà c'est réglé
on va passer des heures à se prendre la
tête sur ces histoires d'accord donc il
était un petit peu agacé et après tout
est ce normal un accord de reddition
s'accroît pas des heures a signé voilà
lu et approuvé je renonce à tout ça
sentait qu'il était fâché
maintenant faut que ça accélère en toute
hypothèse ce week-end le samedi 7 mai
nous allons avoir un événement de
présentation de nos candidats l'occasion
donc il faut qu'on puisse avancer là
dessus maintenant ça ça a duré voilà un
petit coup de pression c'est assez
classique dans un jeu de négociation la
ba oui puisqu'en tout ça a pâti si
compliqué de s'entendre avec les
écologistes les communistes
franchement il a suffi que manuel
bompard france un peu les yeux et que
draka tenaces les bleus sourcils et tout
le monde était content oui d'accord on
va s'entendre pas de problème on leur a
quand même offert un joli de goût
regarde et on a marqué écologiste et
sociale en dessous c'est c'est quand
même gentil même concession mais faut
dire que c'est quand même pas passer pas
dit qu'il sera pas facile ne passant
dans puisque les communistes et
écologistes ouvert ne pas avoir
carrément de député s'ils ne s'entendait
pas avec mélenchon donc forcément ça
serait trop bête de se tacher pour des
choses comme comme le nucléaire ou des
choses comme ça qui compte pas tant que
ça on écoute comme russel dont ce
contrat de législature
nous l'avons dit dès le départ vous
mettre d'accord et à remettre à mettre
de côté cette question du nucléaire
d'accord on en parlera plus tard pour on
va mettre de côté des fâcheries mais je
demande à ce que justement nous
puissions avoir un groupe pour que ceux
qui pensent à gauche que nous en avons
besoin ben puisse se dire mais on va
avoir un groupe de députés communistes
qui vont se battre là dessus voir ça
c'est pour les communistes avec les
socialistes tard dans wii on verrouille
circonscription beaucoup plus compliqué
si j'ai bien compris les mains ce matin
dans toute les matinales
des spécialistes qui n'étaient pas
d'accord il n'a qu'une dizaine et cet
accord il est inéluctable il finira par
arriver d'autres qui disent ah non moi
je ne veux pas y croire alors entre
celui qui croyait et celui qui n'y
croyaient pas évidemment on commence par
lesquels celui qui n'y croyaient pas
absolue qui ne croyaient pas c'est
françois bayrou alors lui veut pas y
croire l'idée que la social-démocratie
s'allie avec la gauche anticapitaliste
ça annonce est trop fort donc il a
évoqué la mémoire de jacques delors
passerait de 83 ans dit que c'est le
tournant de la rigueur mais c'est aussi
deux tournois de l'europe c'est à dire
que plutôt que de faire cavalier seul
loin de l'europe on a dit non bavaud
quand même un petit peu resté dans le
serpent monétaire s'entendre avec les
allemands lorsque les socialistes
vont-ils tourner le dos à leur histoire
séquence émotion
comment peuvent-ils signé la fin de tout
ce pour quoi ils se sont battus moi je
crois que cet accord n'ira pas jusqu'au
bout parce que je pense qu'il y a
suffisamment d'hommes et de femmes de
conscience qui ne l'accepterons pas
alors qui paraît au contraire ou parier
sur la cigale valve de porc c'est que
ceux qui sont contre l'accord qui au
contraire sont persuadés qu'ils
liquident va signer avec qui je parle
animal gris portera l'effort d'oreilles
voilà cambadélis ancien pro mac est
premier secrétaire du ps
les négociations durent pour donner
l'impression qu'elles sont durs mais
olivier force et la chèvre de monsieur
seguin il va céder le choix de
l'intégration à mélenchon est déjà actée
par son équipe alors vous connaissez la
chèvre de monsieur seguin c'est qu'ils
en avaient marre d'être raisonnable elle
a envie de sortir de son enclos dinan on
ne sort pas mélenchon va être croquée
ouais mais franchement la social
démocratie n en pouvait plus lavaur vide
radicalité banque est en écoute c'est
pierre jouve est ce matin sur europe 1
j'entends beaucoup ce sujet notamment
sur la radicalité où j'entends notamment
des anciens m'expliquer que la
radicalité serait incompatible avec le
parti socialiste mais enfin la
radicalité sais pas ce qui a fait aussi
les plus grandes heures du parti
socialiste la radicalité sais pas ce qui
a amené par exemple aujourd'hui c'est la
date anniversaire le front populaire à
faire les congés payés c'est pas ce qui
nous a amenés à baisser le temps de
travail c'est pas ce qui nous a amenés à
faire l'abolition de la peine de mort
cette radicalité et bien si voilà
florent de la montagne sont en vie elles
sont ouvertes tout appétissante
attention pas se faire croquer par le
grand méchant mélenchon merci merci pour
ce regard pour commencer ce débat merci
stéphane on va commencer par un petit
point socialistes ils sont pas là ce
soir mais vous vous participez en partie
à ces discussions alexis corbière qu'est
ce qui coince ce soir exactement avec
avec les négociateurs socialistes est-ce
qu'ils sont trop gourmands c'est ça il
demande trop de circo gagnable
déjà bon jeu rendre hommage à ceux qui
sont vraiment dans les négociations moi
je suis pas directement autour de la
table mais pourquoi vous présentez des
choses comme ça je veux dire moi j'ai
envie de dire aux gens méfiez-vous des
accords qui seraient trop rapide parce
que d'abord ce qu'on a voulu c'est
qu'ils aient une discussion politique
qui prend du temps et bon stéphane
blakowski nous nous a quittés je
comprends qu'on puisse prendre ça avec
de l'humour mais on peut pas pendant des
mois nous avoir servi le fait que
l'union était impossible qu'on était
tous des imbéciles et voir maintenant
que quand il ya une discussion qui a eu
aucune discussion sérieuse elle prend un
certain temps et après vous auriez pu la
faire avant ben non justement ce qu'il
fallait qui en résulta élections
présidentielles qui crée des conditions
qui est une force qui d'un point de vue
électoral est en capacité de faire
l'union judo dire j'ai une phrase de
l'apica quelqu'un qui m'agace ou ans
c'était françois hollande mais il disait
c'est pas tellement l'union fait la
force non mais c'est la
prononcer un discours bien c'est du
france hollande c'est non mais je
trouvais que pour le 2nd vrai il disait
c'est pas l'union qui fait la force qui
ne phrase connaissons c'est la force qui
peut faire l'union le premier jusqu'à ce
que tout le monde contester le
leadership de chacun c'était sans fin et
vous aviez évidemment un jeu de dupes de
gens qui parlaient d'unités c'était
ridicule parce que tous voulaient
l'unité derrière les électeurs quelque
part ont tranché une ligne politique à
savoir que c'est le programme qui est le
nôtre qui marchent devant à partir là ce
que nous faisons nous prendrons nos
responsabilités au sort gran qui
marchaient devant oui mais c'est notre
structure qu'il n'ya pas grand chose non
plus sur le fond à négocier dans ce vote
côté c'est tout l'inversé mais je veux
dire avec toute l'affection que j'ai
pour lui les uns prédisaient les
documents ce n'est pas une reddition
faut arrêter de dire ça mais évidemment
que appartion vous avez une
responsabilité 22% sur votre candidat
est votre programme sepa pour comment
dirais-je le charme de monsieur
mélenchon que vous ne cessez de
critiquer c'est d'abord sur les idées
prenez pas laissés sur la retraite avec
les socialistes
alors justement mais
je n'ai pas d'accord sur le moment je
pense ou n'est pas d'accord sur la
livraison d'armes à l'ukraine avec la
société pour quoi vous négociez jo qui
accepte je prends la porte je prend le
premier point je prend le premier point
alors entonné socialiste non mais même
ce procès est un brillant pas tu voulais
on peut tous avaient fait une litanie
mais je peux leur adresse que je donnais
socialiste est ce qu'on est contre la
retraite à 60 ans en 1981 dans les 110
propositions de françois mitterrand y
avait la retraite à 60 ans jamais dire
on est fidèle au socialisme quand on se
bat pour la retraite à 60 ans donc
n'inventez pas des thèmes qui sont des
fautes m et après le reste on peut
continuer à les décliner je crois que
quand on est socialiste on est attaché à
la critique de la 5ème république parce
que l'histoire du parti socialiste et
non pas d'aller ses filles au nez dans
le refus de françois mitterrand de la
vème république je peux vous prendre
tous les thèmes c'est un retour aux
sources alors moi je pense avec d'autres
mois avec jean luc mélenchon qui milité
au sein du parc chez parti socialiste
comme cause l'évolution tellement
éloigné de ses bases étaient telles
qu'il fallait rompre avec le ps
participé à ce que nous avons fait pour
qu'on puisse reconstruire les marchés
astres est une force sociale qui recrée
un espoir dans ce pays alors je ne sais
pas si on gagnera je le souhaite mais
c'est ça l'objectif il est juste
quelques fois pour commencer
je compte sur le fond programmatique on
a avancé mais manuel bon port qui mène
les négociations là dit il faut aussi
que nos amis socialistes avec toute
l'affection que j'ai désormais pour eux
comprennent qu'il ya eu aussi un
résultat électoral et qu' ils ne peuvent
pas être trop gourmand donc on a l'air
ce moment de discussion et on va y
arriver parce que je pense qu'olivier
fort et les négociateurs sont des gens
raisonnables c'est un peu normal combien
coûtent les chiffres dans tous ça nous
aussi on a fait plus que des gestes donc
on va y arriver mais chacun comprendra
que bon il faut trouver le point
d'équilibré
et je pense aussi que les socialistes
sont face à des débats internes que je
prends sérieux je vois qu'il ya toute
une série de grandes personnalités
incontournables qui ne quittent ans
qu'il a eus tiercé voilà faucheux
d'emmanuel macron dans là dedans c'est
dommage moi je pense que les gens ils
veulent ils veulent qu'on gagne en juin
c'est la seule chose qui les intéresse à
ce petit point sur les socialistes
puisqu'ils sont ils font en négociation
rené dit comment vous comprenez ce qui
se joue en ce moment ce qui est très
intéressant il faut distinguer les
négociations en fait l'accord est déjà
conclue entre les insoumis et les
communistes c'est normal parce que il
logiquement politiquement
programmatiquement ils n'étaient pas si
éloignées que ça sur tous les sujets
environnementaux et sociaux en
particulier il y avait un sujet qui
fâche et c'était nucléaire vous l'avez
dit il a été rangé sous la table on en
parlera plus tard dès lors l'accord est
naturelle après j'ai regardé
attentivement cet accord pour le coup on
peut comprendre que pour certains
socialistes ce soit difficile d'avaler à
peu près les mêmes éléments vous avez
évoqué la désobéissance dans certaines
circonstances aux règles européennes
évidemment ça pose un problème à
certains socialistes il ya aussi dans
l'accord qui a été conclu avec les
communistes aujourd'hui un certain
nombre de renationalisation extrêmement
importante les banques généralistes là
les autoroutes les aéroports edf angie
tout ça c'était pas dans le programme
d'anne hidalgo et des socialistes ces
dernières années des accords vient le
temps des socialistes on n'est pas
contre ça mais attendez mais en tout cas
c'était pas ne s'était pas leur
programme jeudi d'accord c'est cédric
mans on n'aime pas on se renie pas quand
un apport masturbatoire certaines
activités jeux par dessus de la campagne
présidentielle c'était pas le programme
d'oeil à l'histoire le retour à la
retraite à 60 ans c'était pas le
président al gore c'était la retraite à
62 ans sans parler effectivement des
livraisons d'armes à l'ukraine ou encore
du sort du pass vaccinale d'ailleurs
puisque vous étiez et vous êtes pour son
abolition a que les socialistes avaient
voté donc on voit bien que sur le fond
c'est quand même beaucoup plus compliqué
pour les socialistes de le signer après
on peut penser qu'ils vont faire pour
une raison simple c'est que la direction
actuelle du parti socialiste en
l'occurrence conduite par olivier faur
d'abord elle s'est énormément engagés
dans cette voie et ensuite en fait
depuis cinq ans cette direction là oui
levier fort le premier a été le
principal procureur du quinquennat de
françois hollande qui évidemment il
s'agit dit il s'agit d'éradiquer de
tourner cette page là dans la tête des
insoumis et de la direction actuelle du
ps donc dès lors qu'il a été lui-même
pendant cinq ans le principal procureur
du quinquennat françois hollande qui l'a
qualifiée de trahison ce qui a
d'ailleurs à mon avis contribuer aussi
affaiblir la candidate socialiste à la
présidentielle y avait aucune raison de
voter socialiste dès lors que les
socialistes eux-mêmes faisait le procès
de leur passage au pouvoir pense que la
direction du ps signera cet accord reste
à savoir si effectivement enfin combien
de socialistes de base de baron
d'éléphants d'anciens ministres voilà
resteront sur le parti de jean jaurès
ian brossât on va parler avec stéphanie
des pierres qui nous attendent devant le
siège des insoumis suivi cette journée
de l'accord avec les communistes dans le
détail dans un tout petit instant mais
votre regard ça m'intéresse de savoir ce
sont des gens qui ne se sont pas parlé
depuis
des années dix ans presque les
socialistes et et la france insoumise il
ce repas on peut comme ça en quelques
semaines à retrouver une langue commune
franchement ça les concerne en tout cas
pour ce qui concerne les communistes
nous avons toujours discuter avec à peu
près tout le monde à la fois avec les
socialistes et avec les insoumis il ya
d'ailleurs beaucoup de communes en
france qui sont dirigés par des équipes
dans lesquelles on retrouve l'ensemble
de ses composantes de la gauche donc moi
en tout cas je pense que c'est plutôt
une bonne nouvelle que la gauche
retrouve le chemin du dialogue qu'elle
soit capable de se rassembler à travers
l'ensemble de ses cessions lui quelque
chose au fond c'est ce que dit alexis
corbière du kiosque qui impulsait
l'union est pas la même en tout cas ce
qui est sûr c'est que le choix qu'il a
fait de tendre la main à l'ensemble des
composantes de la gauche contribue au
fait que nous en soyons là aujourd'hui
et pour ce qui nous concerne nous au
parti communiste il nous paraît bien
naturel de participer à un tel un tel
rassemblement éclair sommes très heureux
du fait de pouvoir se présenter de
manière rassembler où c'est le premier
mais les gens ne nous parlait que de ça
quand est-ce que vous rassembler quand
est ce que vous êtes capable de vous
présenter unis devant les électeurs
qu'on y soient arrivés c'est une bonne
chose alors on va essayer de comprendre
sur quoi vous êtes rassemblés avec
stéphanie des pierres parce qu'on a
l'impression qu'on peut se rassembler
côté écolo qui seront rassemblés mais
pas tout à fait sur la même ligne avec
les communistes bonsoir stéphanie des
pierres vous avez suivi cette longue
journée de négociations ps pc on
commence par le pc qui officialise donc
un accord flambant neuf ce soir
oui un peu avant à 18 heures la fumée
blanche rose rouge peut-on dire est
tombé le pcf a officialisé son accord
avec les insoumis jean luc mélenchon est
arrivé quelques minutes plus tard ici à
son qg les deux formations de gauche
vont donc concourir sous une bannière
commune pour les législatives les
communistes présenteront des candidats
dans une cinquantaine de
circonscriptions dont celles des 11
sortant et cinq autres qu'ils jugent
gagnable si l'on 15 députés élus ils
pourront à garder un groupe communiste
autonome à l'assemblée nationale mais
ils s'engagent à défendre un programme
commun avec les insoumis le smic à 1400
euros la retraite à 60 ans la
nationalisation d'edf et des autoroutes
la sixième république et enfin sur
l'europe
ils s'engagent à défendre une
désobéissance aux règles de l'union
européenne chaque fois qu'ils le
jugeront au portant je reviens vers vous
ian brossât pour vous faire réagir dans
un instant mais côté socialiste puisque
là et on est en direct 19h40 sept du
nouveau ou pas
19h47 ça fait plus de dix heures que le
parti socialiste et sa délégation sont
au siège des insoumis et négocié et ça
coince sur le fond les termes de
désobéissance aux règles de l'union
européenne comme le stipule l'accord
signé avec les communistes et les verts
est une formation une formulation pardon
qui a du mal à passer chez les
socialistes et puis il ya surtout des
désaccords sur la forme sur les
circonscriptions et leur répartition
mettons un candidat insoumis mettons un
candidat socialiste vous l'avez entendu
à la mi-journée manuel bompard pour les
insoumis a mis la pression sur les
socialistes estimant qu'ils étaient un
peu trop exigeant au regard de leur
score à la présidentielle cela a agacé à
côté socialiste mais les discussions ne
sont pas rompues les insoumis explique
on va y arriver les négociations
pourraient se terminer très tard ce soir
mais c'est ce soir ou jamais dit on du
côté de la france insoumise manuel
bompard négociateur en chef disais tout
à l'heure on ne reviendra pas demain ce
soir ou jamais donc merci merci beaucoup
stéphanie des pierres je reviens vers
vous et ian brossât donc vous y
retrouver enceinte une cinquantaine de
circonscriptions t5 gagnable donc ça
c'est un progrès un groupe assuré c'est
ça que vous recherchez avant tout pour
sauver votre gros
y'a quand même des électeurs qui votent
et connaissant même décideront cartes et
des cravates des crises est
effectivement un accord qui va nous
permettre d'avoir une représentation
renforcer sans doute je l'espère en tout
cas à l'assemblée nationale mais ce
n'est pas l'essentiel l'essentiel c'est
d'écouter ce que nous disent les gens
comme je voulais raconter tout à l'heure
aujourd'hui ce que veulent les gens de
gauche c'est qu'on soit unie c'est qu'on
soit rassemblés et donc si nous étions
restés au resto
je ne pense pas du tout ça et c'est
parce que les gens nous disent ce que
veulent les gens c'est que leur vie
change c'est que le pouvoir d'achat
augmente c'est que les salaires
augmentent c'est que les pensions de
retraite augmente c'est qu'on en finisse
avec des réformes qui sont
systématiquement des récentes journées
de fabien roussel qui a affirmé sans
cesse cette différence avec jean luc
mélenchon la république notamment peut y
avoir un certain nombre de nuances mais
vous savez gérer le nucléaire le
nucléaire sortie du nucléaire auquel
vous vous êtes opposé n'est pas dans
l'accord enfin il a été nya pas alors
qu'il est dans l'accord avec les verts à
moi ya une chose que je ne comprends pas
c est ce qu on peut faire des accords de
quoi gérer ce gamin n'a changé sur vous
la gauche est toujours été divisés sur
cette question toujours mais ça nous a
pas empêché de gouverner ensemble et si
on raisonnait comme ça jamais on ne
gouvernerait nulle part ensemble bien
sûr qu'il ya des nuances bien sûr qu'il
ya des différences et l'hypocrisie
l'hypocrisie serait était de faire
semblant qu'elle n'existe pas bien sûr
qui est assez différent cela il ya aussi
une coalition avec un jour de la sortie
du nucléaire dans l'accord avec les
communistes on en parle avec les
écologistes c'est compatible ça va de
soi parce que à la fin il ya qu un seul
accord de coalition mais bien sûr mais
qu'est ce qui intéresse dire j'en sais
quoi la priorité des français c'est la
question du pouvoir d'achat c'est la
question des salaires et donc est ce
qu'on est capable de mettre en place un
gouvernement qui s'engage à augmenter
les salaires qu'ils s'engagent à
redonner du pouvoir d'achat aux français
a renoué avec des réformes heureuse
plutôt que des réformes qui nous
pourrissent la vie c'est quand même ça
le grand sujet des gens essayent il ya
aussi des milliers je vous disais tout à
l'heure de collectivités qui sont
dirigés par des équipes de la gauche
rassemblée ya les mêmes nuances et ça
nous empêche pas de les diriger ensemble
sans pour autant que ce soit le désordre
bonsoir adrien brèche et merci d'avoir
su patienter vous êtes à vivavoice
revient voice pardonnez moi
si toutes chaudes sondage viavoice
est-ce que ce que disait gagnent gros ça
correspond aux attentes des français on
vient bien vu tous ses appels à l'union
il ya une primaire populaire qui a été
critiquée ou au contraire plutôt bien
regarder d'un bon oeil est ce qu'il ya
vraiment cette cette volonté de les voir
négocié entre les deux tours après la
présidentielle alors la volonté de les
voir négocier c'est difficile à dire je
pense plutôt surtout qu'on est sur un
accord qui vise des électorats qui se
ressemble en fait pas forcément
les électorats entre eux mais disons que
chaque partie a plus ou moins le même
électorat à gauche donc on est on l'a
très bien vu sur le vote utile qui pose
assez peu de problèmes puisque les
dynamiques se reportent assez facilement
sur le vote jean luc mélenchon au
premier tour je pense qu'il ya un peu de
sujet ici on est tous on est tous un peu
concerné par ça on a un sujet des
lectorats qui regarde ça de manière
peut-être un peu plus lointaine que nous
et en voyant plutôt les points communs
que les divisions et puis on a le débat
doctrinal e idéologique qui nous
intéresse tous ces mois le 1er mai mais
qui qui qui nous mais peut-être aussi
peut-être à distance parfois des
réalités des perceptions peuvent avoir à
la fois les français les électeurs de
gauche donc je pense qu'il faut
simplement avoir un petit peu ces deux
points en tête effectivement on a des
points communs entre les électorats de
gauche on le voit sur le vote utile on
le voit on est prêt à sacrifier
peut-être quelques convictions si tant
est qu'on en soit conscient au profit
d'un candidat ou d'une coalition qu'ils
soient majoritaires et compris ps et un
somme il ya eu un vote une part
importante de vote socialiste exactement
mais alors ensuite on peut discuter de
de la capacité de l'électorat insoumis
et de l'électorat de la future coalition
en tout cas de d'aller chercher des
électorats qui sont peut-être pas
forcément les siens actuellement on a
beaucoup parlé la différence entre le
vote marine le pen et le vote jean luc
mélenchon en tout cas pour le vote jean
luc mélenchon qui a été celui du premier
tour globalement on peut on peut assurer
qui peut se retrouver dans à peu près
tous les partis de gauche et donc dans
une coalition qui les réunit sur cette
question
des dires des contenus d accord est il
possible d'avoir des différences dans
les accords signés par les différentes
formations depuis tout à l'heure je vous
vois
ironisé là dessus mais
c'est que vous êtes très cultivée en 97
vous qu'on sait que la corde à gauche
plurielle il est extrêmement riche et
dense c'était un rapport de force du ps
qui synthétisait tout le monde c'était
silence dans les rangs mais si renault
doucement doucement mais plutôt tendance
à déléguer justement celle là n'est pas
faire la gauche plurielle on a vu le
résultat on a vu le résultat exactement
gina mais vous le confirmer ce que j'en
sais rien c'était très faible du point
de vue de l'homogénéité politique et
chacun de déléguer à des ponts qu'il a
cru pouvoir renouveler la stratégie en
2002 et ça a été un échec nous ont fait
d'un verse aux banques vous ne trouverez
jamais dans l'histoire de plus ou moins
c'est peu plusieurs décennies d'abord
d'un discussion de fond qui a lieu
évidemment liens de brossard a raison de
dire que si vous allez 2 suite à la
difficulté en perdant ce que je t'ai du
ce est sur le point de départ vous ne
ferez pas l'essentiel est d'abord ce
qu'attendent les gens pour créer une
dynamique positive dans le pays c'est
qu'on change la vie vraiment augmenter
les salaires défendre les services
publics créent des conditions
effectivement d'un autre rapport de
force social qui a été extrêmement
dégradée et c'est même d'ailleurs à ce
que
ça m'avait échappé mais précision pour
la gagner le quinquennat nous oblige
quoi à garder d'abord notre électorat le
quinquennat aujourd'hui il a tué la vie
parlementaire c'est une reproduction
mécanique de la présidentielle qu'est ce
qui se passe le camp du gagnant reste
relativement mobiliser le camp des
perdants et totalement démobilisés le
choix que nous avons fait et je félicite
élevé et le pcf de le faire avec nous
j'espère que le ps reviendra de dire
mettons un enjeu dans les initiatives
qui viennent parce que je vais vous dire
emmanuel macron est le président le plus
mal élu il fait 38 % des électeurs
inscrits je vais vous livrer un scoop il
est élu au second tour essentiellement
dans un rejet de madame le pen
lui nommé ça compte les inscriptions est
ce qu'on appelle l'électorat 40,7
millions de gens donc ça veut dire que
avec la démission forcée maladie mais
c'est nous notre stratégie c'est pas
compliqué d'or eut donc conomie je garde
et je termine à tu comment je garde
mobiliser notre électorat à la fois des
gens qui ont voté mélenchon et de tous
nos amis si je mets pas d'enjeu je vais
vous dire les gens ils en ont rien à
fiche des prêts intéressants si je mets
pas d'enjeu en dix ans les gens ne
viendront pas voté par sympathie pour
les prêts donc l'intérêt que vous avez à
la fois les jours
je me félicite que lv le pc même le ps
demain se disent malgré des différences
cola l'enjeu est tellement important
cette changer la vie et on verra ça des
difficultés on discute sur le fond et on
essaie d'y arriver et on peut gagner
cette stratégie est d'aller cette
stratégie qui a la faune stratégie de
communication et politique l éthique et
politique ne suis qu'une question il ya
un message et elle est extrêmement
habile sa jauge approuve totalement ce
que vous dites est effectivement l
extrême habitaient les pensées depuis le
soir de la défaite en fait puisque jean
luc mélenchon qui a perdu pour la
troisième fois consécutive au premier
tour de la présidentielle a inventé
aussitôt un troisième tour je suis un
quatrième tour voire un cinquième tour
dans la dans la rue en répétant
effectivement que emmanuel macron avait
été très mal et lui alors que lui il
aurait été quasiment au quasiment
vainqueur donc c'est une façon de nous
continuer à mobiliser ses troupes c'est
vrai
alors c'est quand même plutôt et magnin
le pont qui a été élu deux fois mais
dans un deuxième temps lexicaux revient
à raison le principal risque pour les
camps qui ont perdu la présidentielle à
chaque fois depuis l'instauration du
quinquennat il ya vingt ans c'est la
démobilisation leurs électeurs aux
élections législatives qui suivent on
l'a vu à chaque fois effectivement il ya
cinq ans les insoumis ont perdu huit
points entre les 19 et demi de jean-luc
mélenchon à la présidentielle et les 11%
leurs candidats aux législatives donc
afficher et jean luc mélenchon de
premier ministre inventons fait mettre
en scène cet enjeu ça vise effectivement
évité une démobilisation et
troisièmement en fait dans cette affaire
tout le monde a bougé parce que c est
exactement l inverse de la stratégie
qu'avait essai de jean luc mélenchon en
2017 la prévention ne voulait absolument
pas se poser en rassembleur de la gauche
il récusait même le mot de gauche qu'il
jugeait a jamais eu à jeter aux
oubliettes dès lors qu'il avait été
légitimée par françois hollande c'est ce
qu'il a répété lundi
on a discuté passé qui va parler nous
d'union populaire ce que je dépense
évoqué
aignan louisiane cherche à rassembler
oui mais vous n'êtes pas vraiment le mot
gauche alexis corbière n'a toujours moi
je suis un homme de gauche s'est dit non
mais le mot mais bon je vais utiliser
mais vous et moi on aime l'histoire vous
savez très bien que dans la longue
histoire d'entre eux - réclame elle a
plus de deux siècles le combat qui est
bien celui de l'émancipation celui du
camp du travail il ya eu plein de mots
et le problème que nous avons
aujourd'hui c'est aussi un débat
sémantique il ya des mots ce que je veux
dire c'est que ce problème avec le mot
ce que je veux vous dire c'est bien sûr
je suis pour l'union de la gauche mais
je pense qu'à la différence des années
70 il suffit pas de dire ce mot pour que
les gens comprennent ce que vous voulez
dire à trop évoquer le passé moi qui
suis un amoureux du passé
certaines choses donc quand nous dise
quand nous disons que nous voulons faire
autre chose c'est ça aussi c'est
important parce que malgré tout
l'expérience du passé est synonyme
d'échec pour beaucoup de gens se
rappeler à tout le monde a vu bouger
j'entendais les enjeux de ces
idées parfois changer foncez sont quand
même son troisième échec à la
présidentielle
et donc quand il se rend compte que non
il se rend compte peut-être que la
prochaine fois il a dit un truc positif
sur ce qu'on fait parce que de
gauche au premier tour la présidentielle
et notamment les candidatures de fabien
roussel qui racontera larmes c'était ma
question jean luc mélenchon négocié
parle avec tous les partenaires de
gauche peut-être se rend-il compte que
la prochaine fois il faudra y aller unis
et ne peut pas gagner seul jusqu'à
présent est-ce que vous ne regrettez pas
du coup d'avoir présenté
est d'ailleurs ce qui fait que la gauche
progresse au premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle puisqu'elle progresse de
4 points par rapport à 2010 est c'est
aussi la candidature de fabien roussel
qui a amené à gauche ramenée à gauche
des électeurs qui en était qu on était
partis et on peut retourner le passé
dans tous les sens moi ce qui
m'intéresse ce sont les élections
législatives qui arrive et ce que je
vois et alexis corbière a eu raison de
le dire c'est qu'on a enfin des
élections législatives qui vont avoir un
intérêt c'est à dire que l'inversion du
calendrier électoral avait complètement
dévitalisées les élections législatives
avec effectivement des élections
législatives qui ne consistait qu'à
confirmer le résultat de l'élection
présidentielle
enfin on va avoir des élections
législatives qui vont permettre aux
électeurs de choisir un projet est ce
qu'on veut la retraite à 60 ans ou est
ce qu'on veut la retraite à 65 ans
est-ce qu'on veut l'augmentation des
salaires ou est ce qu'on veut à nous
beau des cadeaux pour les actionnaires
ce sont ces questions là que les
électeurs pourront trancher et avec au
bout la possibilité d'une victoire c'est
pas rien quand même et donc je pense que
bien sûr on peut regretter ce qui s'est
passé à la présidentielle mais en tout
cas ce qu'on a commencé à faire à la
présidentielle est aussi porteur
d'espoir pour ces élections du fabien
roussel qui twitte aujourd'hui sa joie
de l'accord qui 1,3 mail vie fait penser
à cette date anniversaire si l'on ait
fait un beau ligue 2 36 3 mai 36 t
comparable franchement la coalition lyon
blue mais est ce qui est en train de
s'ingérer aujourd'hui vous le verrez une
fois qu'on aura gagné en tout cas l'idée
qu' on doit se fixer cet objectif là
c'est évidemment ce serait très
enthousiasmant pose une question dans
mais d'après vous d'accord je penserai
lacroix simple moi je prends comparables
je me suis pense que c'est comparable je
prends l inverse aussi dans la nature
des attaques contre nous toujours pareil
manipulés par l'étranger ralliement et
renoncements sur les principes si vous
non je parle pas de vous mais dans la
presse actuellement les critiques ça
nécessiterait une autre émission j'ai lu
des ouvrages sur les années 30 conduit
paronnaud des dix chez renault relisais
tout salamagne la nature des attaques
que l'on subit aujourd'hui c'est un
échec économique c'est pas sérieux
économique ans est le même la même chose
qui était contre le front populaire il
ya une affiche terrible contre le front
populaire qui en ouvriers écrasés par
les 40 heures en dix ans la réduction du
temps de travail ce sera le chaos
économique on nous a toujours sorti ça
et on nous dit aujourd'hui la même chose
s'est passé au surcroît inconnu moi je
pense qu'il ya dans ce pays une attente
très forte et aussi j'oublie pas pour
terminer je vous donne la parole sur les
questions stratégiques
je reviens pas surpasser mais il ya
aussi 12 à 13 millions de gens qui se
sont abstenus et sociologiquement ces
gens sont souvent ceux des milieux
populaires et créer l'espoir c'est non
seulement garder notre camp mobilisés
mais si je le souhaite j'espère qu'on
arrivera pouvoir aussi 1 2 3 millions
pourquoi pas supplémentaire de jouer les
scellés on peut gagner c'est ça
l'objectif
adrien broches sur les attentes
justement des français clémentine autain
dans libération ce matin expliqué qu'au
fond cet accord de coalition c'était la
suite logique du non au référendum sur
le traité constitutionnel européen
est ce qu'il ya un son de gravité à
gauche aujourd'hui qui pourrait se
retrouver tél le front populaire si
cette coalition marché et pourquoi pas
été été représenté une fille née au
gouvernement je pense qu'effectivement
la question c'est d'abord de savoir ce
qu'il y à davantage de points communs
que 2.2 dissensus à gauche et une fois
qu'on a identifié les points de 10 ans
us savoir la nature et le degré qu'il ya
justement entre les les différents
désaccord qui peuvent y avoir à gauche
alors si on prend un certain nombre de
sujets et moi je suis dans le rôle du
commentateur donc c'est toujours
beaucoup plus simple mais mais sur le
rapport évidemment au nucléaire sur le
rapport aux identités à la république
sur le rapport à l'international c'est
au parti à eux mêmes de trancher encore
une fois je je je pense qu'il faut pas
surestimer la
percée électorale dans l'ailé
parce que les consciences citoyennes
d'un certain nombre de désaccords qui
peuvent être très importants pour nous
beaucoup moins important pour un certain
nombre d'électeurs à gauche qui encore
une fois je pense se retrouve plutôt
derrière cette dynamique d'union donc
voilà je pense que est ce qu'il y a des
choses qui rassemble à gauche si oui
quelles sont les choses qui ne rassemble
pas quelle est la puissance des choses
qui qui qui fait que les gauches ne sont
pas en accord les unes avec les autres
surtout qu'on voit qu'il ya des mêmes
théoriquement des décalages puisque le
rapport au libéralisme économique et le
rapport au libéralisme culturel ne sont
plus totalement corrélée c'est à dire
que plus on se déplace vers la gauche de
la gauche disons radical anticapitaliste
c'est pas pour autant qu'on va se
trouver sur une gauche qui va être très
anti-libérale sur le plan d'aidé des des
moeurs et du rap ya une attente mais il
ya évidemment des difficultés je pense
des dissensions intellectuelle qu'il
faut pas sous-estimer l'union de la
gauche à portée de la main merci
beaucoup to be continued comme on dit en
bon français on verra ce que ça donnera
avec les socialistes en tout cas les
éléphants l'ancien premier ministre
menace de quitter le parti marie que ça
va se faire ça va se faire on pensait
tous que ça va se faire j'espère en tout
cas oui
merci beaucoup merci d'être venus
débattre sur le plateau des cp vous
rester avec moi alors renouvellé on va
continuer à parler de la gauche votre
dernier essai anatomie d'une trahison ne
lui laisse que peu d'espoir je dirais de
résurrection temps elle a rompu à vos
yeux avec ses valeurs historiques le
progrès l'émancipation l'universalisme
la laïcité at elle tout de même quelques
petites chances de résurrection malgré
loupé à des manuels macron sur la social
démocratie on a encore plein de
questions à vous poser comme les skis ce
sujet signé nicolas coadout regardez si
on vous invite aujourd'hui renaud dély
promis ce n'est pas pour vous parler de
jean lassalle savamment arnaud délit que
je regrette profondément ce qu'il a
écrit même si ses fins un faux
chefs mais de l'état de la gauche une
gauche qui aurait trahi le progrès et
son dessin universaliste tout un
programme mais avant cela voici votre cv
renaud dély vous êtes écrivain
journaliste passé par libé loeb marianne
puis france info et arte alors autant
dire que sur cette gauche divisée vous
en connaissez un rien trop mélenchon et
aux rousses est un véritable gouffre
idéologique qui s'est creusé au fil des
mois sur de nombreux sujets le nucléaire
ou salée pour mais dense on veut en
sortir la sécurité dont roussel fait une
priorité quand mélenchon fustige les
violences policières votre anatomie a
parfois plutôt désert d'autopsié vous
déclariez au lendemain de l'élection
présidentielle que cette gauche n'est
plus qu elle risque même de sortir de
l'histoire politique et électoral de ce
pays votre diagnostic est limpide et
sans appel mais un bon médecin complète
par une prescription alors docteur daily
qu'elle ordonnance pour que la gauche
renoue avec ses idéaux de progrès et
surtout qui pour l'incarner la parole
est à vous
alors avant d'en venir à leur donnant ce
du docteur delhi où va s'arrêter quand
même quelques minutes sur sur le
diagnostic d'abord vous parlez de la
gauche comme d'un bloc idéologiquement
plutôt que d'une gauche socialiste
écologiste
j'essaye d'arrimer dans ce livre le
destin histoire de la gauche à la notion
de progrès en fait c'est la gauche des
lumières dont je parle c'est à dire que
j'essaye de raconter que depuis la fin
du xviiie siècle jusqu'au début du
xxième la gauche française était arrimé
à cette idée de progrès héritée des
lumières et que c'était en quelque sorte
une gauche qui étaient eux qui avaient
confiance dans l'avenir qui
effectivement croyait dans le progrès
dans l'émancipation individuelle en même
temps que dans la solidarité qui croyait
dans l'universalisme donc dans
l'acceptation de l'autre y compris avec
ses différences plutôt que de verser
dans une forme de crainte de l'avenir
dans une forme parfois de 2 de repli
identitaire et de devenir en quelque
sorte une gauche craintif qui avait
tendance à se replier sur des identités
elle-même morcelé justement avec aussi
un certain nombre de deux tard on va
dire ou de dérives que j'évoque dans cet
ouvrage c'est à dire des comportements
du type par exemple de l'indignation
j'ai pu essayer de d'autopsié pour
reprendre votre image la gauche indigné
cette l'indignation c'est un réflexe
extrêmement légitime est extrêmement
sain
ça ne fait pas un projet politique et
surtout ça ne bâtit pas un projet
politique tournée vers l'avenir et trop
souvent toute une frange de la gauche
ces dernières décennies depuis une
quinzaine d'années d'ailleurs a eu
tendance à faire simplement de
l'indignation à un oriflamme qui serait
suffisant pour construire un projet
c'est pas le cas alors comment s'opère
ce que vous appelez une trahison parce
que les mots sont forts
tourner le dos à l'avenir trahir avec
l'idée de progrès comment à quelles sont
les différentes étapes parce qu'à un
moment de bascule
hausse est progressif je pense que c'est
progressif ya pas un moment de bascule
n'y a pas un événement précis mais il ya
un moment où la gauche française et sait
pas d'ailleurs une
une évolution qui était propre à la
gauche française c'est aussi une
évolution qu'on a pu voir dans une
frange dont certains un certain nombre
de soupe de gauche en particulier gauche
de gouvernement en europe mais nombre
d'entre elles se sont remises justement
se sont établis et son amour revenu au
pouvoir dans certains pays on peut
penser par exemple à l'allemagne à
l'espagne au portugal en tout cas il ya
une succession d'événements qui sont
liés d'une part à la mondialisation
c'est-à-dire l'incapacité notamment de
la gauche de gouvernement de la
social-démocratie essentiellement qui
était au pouvoir au début des ados début
du 21e siècle dans 12 des 15 pays de
l'union de l'époque à réguler a amendé à
contrôler la mondialisation est ce qui
fait que la mondialisation est devenu un
terme quasiment démoniaque indemnisé par
toute une frange de la gauche ce qui n'a
pas de sens la médiation n'est pas n'est
ni bonne ni mauvaise en elle-même ça
dépend ce qu'on en fait comment la
réguler la mondialisation ce concept là
qui est extrêmement floues mais qui peut
effectivement généré beaucoup de
craintes il a été extrêmement bénéfique
ces dernières décennies dans des tas de
pays crise là bas en afrique ça a
contribué à l'envol d'un grand nombre de
pays or face à une telle évolution de la
mondialisation qui a évidemment des
répercussions aussi par exemple dans la
révolution numérique ou aussi d'ailleurs
évidemment dans défi climatique
la gauche s'est tellement retrouver en
fait désarmés que par crainte par peur
par peur de l'avenir par peur du real
aussi en quelque sorte par peur vous la
décrivez
ce n'est pas que de la faute des manuels
macro qui lui a quand même dérobé le
concept de progrès progressisme contre
nationale épreuve emmanuel macron est
arrivé qu'on suit c'est à dire bien très
profond c'est à dire que lui il est venu
récolter en quelque sorte cette
désertion de toute une frange de la
gauche du chant progressiste et maniant
la con c'est un symptôme c'est pas lui
qui a créé cette crise si la gauche est
dans cet état là on entend souvent les
responsables de gauche dire c'est de la
faute des manuels macron c'est lui qui
par exemple voulait absolument
renouveler le tête à tête le duel final
avec marine le pen en 2022 comme en 2017
mais c'est pas de la faute des manuels
macron c'est de la faute de la gauche ou
aussi d'ailleurs sur d'autres valeurs et
d'autres programmes magique de la droite
républicaine qui s'est avéré incapable
de construire depuis cinq ans une
alternative donc emmanuel macron il est
arrivé en 2017 il a fait un diagnostic
pour le coup est en quelque sorte il a
dérobé effectivement le l'oriflamme du
progressisme en lui donnant d'ailleurs
en grande partie à notre sens un deux un
sens beaucoup plus individualiste
beaucoup plus libérale beaucoup moins
solidaire et collectif mais il a
récupéré ça parce que la gauche de
gouvernement l'avait abandonnée alors il
ya quand même un divorce avec les
classes populaires parler avec vous de
la gauche du parti socialiste aussi qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui elles votent
massivement pour marine le pen vous
citez cette note de la fondation terra
nova proche du ps quelle majorité
électorale pour 2012 qui estime et d'une
certaine manière que les classes
populaires était perdu pour la cause et
qu'il fallait au fond ce se concentrer
sur les questions sociétales les
questions culturelles vous avez un
chapitre qui s'appelle la gauche
culturaliste contre la feuille de paye
effectivement il ya eu cette note est la
honte et cette fondation terra nova
depuis une dizaine d'années d'essayer
les responsables actuels de tarnos va
d'ailleurs ont essayé de corriger le tir
ils sont revenus sur ce diagnostic l'a77
note considère effectivement quand
quelques en quelque sorte les classes
populaires était à jamais perdue pour la
gauche et qu'elle devait bâtir une
majorité alternative essentiellement ap
s'appuyant sur des minorités on va dire
dès que ce soit des minorités ethniques
ce soit aussi sur les femmes par exemple
aussi sur la cause des femmes et tous
ses combats sociétaux qui sont ô combien
légitime évidemment est important et qui
ont vocation à être brandie défendue par
la gauche qui s'améliore avec son
histoire mais enfin qui peuvent s'y
ajouter il ya un moment où la gauche
quand elle arrive au pouvoir dans les
années 80 au début des années 80 en
france elle est aussi à la fois
l'héritage de la gauche justement
ouvrière populaire mais elle a aussi
récupéré un certain nombre de mouvements
sociétaux qui sont nées notamment au
moment de mai 68 et danser suite bien sa
tante de combat pour les droits des
homosexuels pour les droits des femmes
qui sont récupérés par cette gauche là
parce que cette gauche-là rassembler
réussissait alors eu un moment où la
gauche a considéré que puisque le peuple
en gros pour pour dire à saumos a pas
grand sens tellement il est vague on va
dire puisque ces classes populaires à
dans un stand de région en particulier
du nord et de l'est de la france se sont
mis à voter à l'extrême droite elle
était perdue à jamais elle était à
jamais racistes xénophobes et il
s'agissait d'inventer une majorité et ça
c'était et quand on regarde les
résultats de la présidentielle actuelle
non seulement évidemment est la plus
ancienne récente non seulement
évidemment ce constat de faillite il est
terrible pour les candidats socialistes
communistes écologistes mais même pour
jean luc mélenchon quand on regarde jean
luc mélenchon par exemple dans le
département du pas de calais qui était
un bastion combien extrêmement fort de
la gauche historiquement cette gauche
ouvrière dont parle les insoumis il nous
fallait arrive très loin devant et jean
quinchon fait 15% des voix il est
nettement en dessous de son score
national et par exemple un des
lieutenants jean déclenchant françois
ruffin il le sait il est reparti en
campagne active sur ce thème là à
flixecourt dans la sones terre ouvrière
terre populaire marie le pen a fait
trois fois plus beaux jours d'une
certaine façon la gauche a carrément
trahi le peuple en considérant qu'il
fêtait
justement ce peuple-là ces classes
populaires là notamment dans la région
des hautes france dans l'est de la
france n'accepte r&d instruisez il dit
il a pas vocation à voter en permanence
à l'extrême droite la gauche devrait se
tourner vers lui et on est bon on a bien
vu à quel point la pub est désarçonné
aussi par un mouvement comme celui du
gilet jaune d'ailleurs dont elle n'a pas
bénéficié électoralement par la suite
alors le tournant vous en avez parlé
c'est aussi l'urgence climatique le défi
majeur
conduit d'une certaine façon la gauche
écrivez-vous à se vautrer dans le
catastrophisme vous parlez d'une gauche
hibernatus d'une gauche surgelés
recroquevillée sur elle même qui
jouirait de faire peur ce qui me ce qui
me terrifie ce qui n'affole ce qui me
navre d'ailleurs dans le comportement
d'une grande partie de la gauche s'est
effectivement l'incapacité qu'elle a
aujourd'hui à dessiner un après c'est à
dire que l'urgence climatique le défi
climatique il est là il est
incontournable il faut s'y attaquer
évidemment on peut considérer à raison
ou pas d'ailleurs ensuite mais que tel
ou tel
mental ne vont pas suffisamment et bien
sûr les rapports du giec qui sont il ya
des raisons il ya une urgence mais le
problème de toute une frange de la
gauche c'est qu'elle elle semble là
aussi démunis et qu'elle dépeint une
catastrophe et c'est pas des lendemains
qui chantent pour le coup elle n'arrive
pas à inventer un monde d'après c'est à
dire une façon justement de surmonter
cette catastrophe et on voit toute une
frange à gauche qui faire sans ce qu'on
appelle à collabos logis quand on voit
que par exemple yves cochet ancien
ministre de l'environnement du
gouvernement de lionel jospin un
individu au combien brillant intelligent
mathématicien scientifique est
aujourd'hui convaincu que dans une
quinzaine d'années
bien la catastrophe le mur est là et
qu'il faut qu on circulera tous h à
cheval par exemple et qu'il faut que
l'état investisse massivement dans les
haras nationaux pour remplacer même les
véhicules électriques ou hybrides voilà
on a une vision du monde et du mmm s'est
re choisi un mode de vie qui lui est
propre et qui est parfaite la estimable
mais qui est une illustration me semble
jusqu'au
catastrophiste non seulement je pense
qu'il est purement qu'elle se refuse il
faut alerter et entendons nous bien il
faut alerter il faut agir on peut
considérer qu'on n'agit pas assez vite
mais si on répète tout est foutu s'il ya
toute une frange la gauche qui est comme
ça quand même tout est foutu c'est trop
tard dans ces cas là on se rachète des
suv c'est suicidaire non seulement c'est
ainsi c'est une forme d'impuissance qui
moi me me désole mais de surcroît je
pense que c'est suicidaire par rapport à
cette urgence à laquelle évidemment les
gouvernants quels qu'ils soient doivent
s'attaquer à toute une réflexion sur la
capacité à reproduire une forme
d'intérêt général deux destins
collectifs d'espoir vous avez un dernier
chapitre qui s'appelle le plaisir du
réel d'une certaine façon cesser les
solutions on dirait dans un instant une
petite question si sur les méthodes vous
êtes très dur avec les méthodes de la
gauche qui serait devenu sectariste
punitive incapable de nuances incapable
de complexité une gauche y est exclu
l'opinion dissidente sans même l'étudier
ni la déconstruire une gauche qui verse
aussi dans l'obscurantisme en se méfiant
de la science qui me terrifie c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il ya ce qu'on connaît
pendre sur le réseaux sociaux ce qui ont
tendance de plus en plus incertain du
réseau sociaux en particulier twitter a
viré en fait un torrent de haine le
problème c'est que cette violence
verbale souvent anonymes mais pas
seulement d'ailleurs certains
responsables politiques s'ils s'y
complaisent la tendance aujourd'hui me
semble-t-il a basculé elle aussi dans le
monde réel et elles contribuent à la
dégradation du monde politique
on va pas on va je veux pas rentrer
justement dans ce jeu de dénoncer tel ou
tel
je veux dire que globalement moi
j'essaie d'en appeler dans ce livre
aussi à la nuance à la raison au doute
je pense que l'on grandit de faim que
les changes démocratique se nourrit
s'alimenter se renforce de doute de
remise en cause et malheureusement la
dégradation du débat public la violence
verbale d'abord sur les réseaux sociaux
elle se traduit ensuite dans le monde
politique en échange petit coup surtout
à gauche pas seulement vous dirai ça
existe aussi à droite bien sûr mais à
gauche on cherche toujours à dénoncer
celui qui serait moins pur que l'autre a
excommunié celui qui en gros relèverait
de la gauche molle de la seule de la
gauche sociale libérale de la fausse
gauche le traître en quelque sorte et à
force d'exclure celui qui serait pas
vraiment suffisamment de gauche bah on
se retrouve tout seul ce qui explique
que la gauche au premier tour la
présidentielle tous les candidats
additionnés elle n'a fait que 31% des
voix ian brossât avez raison de rappeler
tout à l'heure que c'était quatre points
de plus qu'il ya cinq ans mais 31% on
est encore loin d'un majoritaire pour
terminer cette conclusion le plaisir du
réel redécouvrir le plaisir est une
condition de la renaissance de la gauche
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que la gauche d'abord doit reprendre
plaisir à l'action est la transformation
du réel et on peut douter d'ailleurs au
regard du contenu de l'accord en
gestation pour les formations de gauche
dont on parlait tout à l'heure on peut
on peut craindre que toute une frange de
la gauche et notamment évidemment les
socialistes perdent ce qu'on appelle à
la culture de gouvernement c'est à dire
qu'on peut aligner effectivement des
mesures notamment des nationalisations
massives des banques d'edf benji des
aéroports des autoroutes etc ou le
retour à la retraite à 60 ans pour tous
si la question du financement et de la
façon dont on change le réel n'est pas
suffisamment crédible là on nourrit des
désillusions
à venir donc le plaisir du contact
lecteur et c'est prendre plaisir
justement à l'affronter y compris donc
parfois à se tromper a échoué à changer
de voie mais toujours à essayer
d'améliorer la situation collective
l'émancipation individuelle et la
solidarité collective anatomie d'une
trahison la gauche contre le progrès 7
en édition de l'observatoire merci
renaud dély vont rester avec moi on a
compris c'est dur mais c'est pas
complètement non un défaitiste et
pessimiste pour la gauche c'est l'heure
d'accueillir nos a franchi pour leur
parti pris pour terminer cette émission
ce soir nouveau rendez vous avec elsa
monde un gars va tous les soirs on va
ouvrir le carnet de campagne ça
s'appelle les 577 et c'est une météo
complète chaque soir de la campagne des
législatives feignies vino chez votre
console novelli de france info nour
joint pour nous parler de l'hôpital et
du big bang que propose le patron ap-hp
martha ici isabelle lasserre du figaro
revient sur l'offensive de la cour
suprême pour remettre en cause le droit
à l'avortement aux états unis noaa
franchi es les voici en pleine forme
j'espère bonsoir à vous trois on va
commencer par vous elsa donc je le
disais tous les soirs désormais jusqu'au
premier tour et au deuxième tour des
législatives
on va suivre grâce à votre chronique
quotidienne et bien les légistes ati ça
s'appelle des 577 alors on commence
aujourd'hui avec un point sur la
majorité bientôt la fin du suspense on
connaîtra une partie des investitures
c'est ça exactement nous promet une
première première self d'investiture a
priori demain on reste un peu au
conditionnel parce que dans la majorité
on aime bien entretenir un petit peu le
flou on ne veut pas vraiment faire un
grand événement on parle d'un simple
dossier de presse pas vraiment de
conférences avec des questions-réponses
200 investiture à peu près alors
attention évidemment nous les
journalistes on va être tentés de
regarder bas ceux qui ne sont pas sur
cette liste en y voyant autant de points
de crispation pas du tout on nous
prévient au qg de campagne ce sera un
panachage certaines d'investiture sont
déjà certaines non les donnera pas
demain histoire de brouiller un petit
peu les pistes ce qui fait énormément
parler ce sont aussi l'état des
relations entre edouard philippe
emmanuel macron glacial sous la menace d
investiture compliqué pour horizon et
oui on parle on beaucoup de choses se
lisent dans la presse il ya beaucoup de
choses qui se passe en coulisses dans
les réunions parmi les entourages alors
on essayait de trouver une photo pour
résumer un peu cette relation entre
edouard philippe emmanuel macron
regarder un président de la république
concentrer sur son tableau excel avec
ses 570 cette ligne autant de
circonscriptions à choisir et qui
réfléchit à comment réduire un maximum
l'influencent l'ambition de son ancien
premier ministre edouard philippe qui
menace de mettre des candidats partout
alors on exagère peut-être un petit peu
mais effectivement dans les entourages
ça tire à boulet rouge ce soir en
sortant de son bureau politique edouard
philippe a voulu quand même calmer un
peu les choses il a parlé d'un climat
travail 2 confiance et même dans la
bonne humeur on sait pas qui on peut
croire en tout cas ce matin il y avait
un juge de paix et un françois bayrou le
patron des députés modem nos confrères
de france inter lui ont demandé comment
il va edouard philippe voilà ce qu'il
répond en tout cas la dernière fois que
je les ai vus c'est à dire hier il avait
l'air en pleine forme comme j'étais en
pleine forme et comme on a bien rigolé
ensemble
j'ai pas toujours été d'accord avec
edouard philippe c'est de notoriété
publique mais enfin on a à construire
ensemble
c'est un peu pervers de demander une
nouvelle de graphie par françois bayrou
et inversement d'ailleurs quand on
connaît les relations entre les exactes
e mail à priori à peut-être une alliance
de circonstance en ce moment on
s'intéresse à présent aux candidats à
l'élection présidentielle les perdantes
deviendront-ils députés ah oui alors
est-ce qu'on va les retrouver à
l'assemblée nationale en juin prochain
jean luc mélenchon eric zemmour n'ont
pas encore décidé ils ont déclaré qu'ils
hésitent et toujours alors si le leader
des insoumis se représente ce sera bien
dans sa circonscription à marseille en
une rumeur l'avait annoncé un temps à
paris eric zemmour lui officiellement il
est très tenté officieusement et bien
dans aucune circonscription il a dépassé
10 7% donc ça peut refroidir un petit
peu et puis une image que l'on ne verra
plus et jean lassalle le député ne
briguera pas de cinquième mandat mais à
la salle peut en cacher un autre
puisqu'il pousse pour une candidature de
son frère julien lassalle vous me
l'apprenez merci merci beaucoup est la
famille on enchaîne avec vous martin
hirsch le patron de l'ap-hp premiers
groupes hospitaliers de france a
transmis à emmanuel macron aujourd'hui
ses propositions pour refus l'hôpital et
il n'y va pas par quatre chemins
effectivement et le terme vous avez
raison c'est refonder en tout cas ils
appellent ça la refondation
il proposa un grand chamboule tout si on
peut dire avec tout un tas d'idées qui
doivent normalement permettre à
l'hôpital public d'affronter les défis
qui l'attendent c'est à dire des
pandémies malheureusement on a vu ce que
c'était des problèmes de manque de lits
de manque de personnel s'adapter aussi à
la des nouvelles technologies la
digitalisation la télémédecine et puis
attiré toute une jeune génération de
médecins qui aujourd'hui bas n'a pas
très envie d'aller à l'hôpital public
pour différentes raisons et qui part
dans le privé ou qui va carrément faire
autre chose alors que veut-il
concrètement changer alors en boulet
plusieurs choses la première c'est
justement pour ces médecins pour ces
soignants c'est d'aller beaucoup plus
loin que le ségur de la santé qui a
permis de revaloriser les salaires mais
on pourrait dire de rattraper de faire
un rattrapage parce qu'il y avait une
major une modération salariale depuis
très longtemps mais l'idée un peu chocs
de marthe ailleurs chez d'en finir avec
le statut national des agents publics
c'est à dire d'arrêter avec une grille
de salaire qui est finalement
aujourd'hui la même que vous soyez à
paris que vous soyez dans le sud de la
france que vous soyez dans le nord parce
que le coût de la vie n'est pas le même
partout et c'est vrai qu'à l'ap-hp à aux
hôpitaux de paris la vraie difficulté de
recrutement ce sont les salaires parce
que la vie est plus chère est souvent et
bien les infirmiers les soignants
doivent faire se loger beaucoup plus
loin que tout près des hôpitaux de la
capitale c'est donc personne ne postule
donc mettre des critères géographiques
et puis autre idée qui
et aussi une petite bombe sociale c'est
d'instaurer des critères individuels des
critères au mérite mérite voilà vous
avez dit le terme alors pour martin
hirsch c'est le seul moyen la seule
façon de pouvoir attirer suffisamment de
soignants pour répondre au besoin à
l'avenir qu avec la pénurie soignant à
l'hôpital on être nombreux la
tarification à l'acte dont on a beaucoup
parlé sur le pétale elle devient quoi
chez martin jarrie la maintiens
étonnamment parce que vous savez que
cette tarification al aqsa fait débat
parce que ça permettrait en tout cas ce
mode de financement est décrié parce
qu'il pousse les hôpitaux à faire un
certain nombre d'actes pour avoir des
budgets martin hier jeudi c'est trop
compliqué d'en changer en revanche il
propose quelque chose d'assez simple
c'est d'abord un seul payeur c'est à
dire que l'hôpital public aujourd'hui
selon lui met beaucoup d'énergie
beaucoup de capacité à se faire payer à
la fois par la sécurité sociale est à la
fois par les différentes complémentaire
aux mutuelles quand il y en a et par
exemple il donne un chiffre il dit que à
l'ap-hp aux hôpitaux de paris ça
représente le travail de 1500 personnes
à rien que pour gérer ses factures donc
voyez propose toute une série de
propositions pour alléger le système le
rendement rigide allégée en finir avec
la bureaucratie et c'est intéressant
parce que ses idées ne sont pas
uniquement rattacher un problème de
moyens alors reste à voir comment
emmanuel macron va se saisir de ces
notes macron de écoutera-t-il martin
exactement en tout cas ça le mérite de
poser le débat parce que c'est vrai que
dans cette campagne bizarrement après
deux ans de kovy des pandémies on n'a
pas tant parler de l'hôpital public que
ça on allait vous pensez que il va
écouter parce qu'il va devoir c'est le
nouveau mac row et dit qu'il va changer
de méthode mais c'est vrai que
c'est une urgence absolue et sélection
jean absolue dont on a mesuré en quelque
sorte pour des tas de raisons fenice
connais beaucoup mieux que moi
de moyens d'organisation la tarification
à l'acte et plein d'autres problèmes on
a mesuré le premier mail délabrement
c'est un peu fort mais on va dire l'état
du système de santé dont on répétait
nous même jusque là on était très fier
nous français le meilleur santé de mire
système de santé public au monde donc là
c'est évidemment ça reste une urgence
pour ce deuxième quinquennat c'est clair
ça va pousser une conférence sociale
encore
oui mais il faut qu'ils bougent c'est
sûr il ya une attente très forte même si
ya pas tant d'idées que ça c'est vrai
qu'au niveau des idées des propositions
qui sont faites c'est assez faiblard la
fin de l'emploi
beaucoup isabelle on termine avec vous
politico a sorti ce qu'on appelle un
scoop mondial même en dévoilant que le
congrès la cour suprême pardonnez-moi
américaine avait l'intention d'enfoncer
un coin dans un droit fondamental le
droit à l'avortement alors est-ce qu'il
est remise en cause est ce qu'on peut
s'attendre à un recul en tout cas la
cour surprême serait visiblement selon
politico sur le point d'infliger la plus
importante limitation aux droits des
femmes de ces cinquante cinquante
dernières années alors le média le média
américain a mis la main sur le projet
d'un juge conservateur qui s'appelle
samuel alito et que prévoit-il bien tout
simplement ils prévoient d'abroger tout
simplement la décision historique de
1973 l'arrêt qu'on appelle l'arrêt roe
against wade et qui faisait de
l'avortement un droit protégé par la
constitution alors si ce projet est
adopté tel quel c'est très simple chaque
état américain sera à l'avenir libre de
décider d'intervenir de d'autoriser ou
d'interdire l'avortement or la cour
suprême a été profondément remanié par
donald trump qui a fait entrer ses
proches et aujourd'hui six magistrats
sur neuf sont conservateurs et ils sont
favorables aux opposants à l'avortement
aux états unis les magistrats de la cour
suprême sont nommés à vie et les
décisions qu'ils prennent c'est très
important parce qu'elles forment le
socle du droit américain ça veut dire
qu'on peut s'attendre à un recul majeur
pour le droit des femmes ou cette
révélation va avoir des conséquences
ça veut dire en théorie si le projet est
accepté et va jusqu'à son terme c'est un
mot en arrière d'un demi siècle le
projet d des magistrats conservateur
fait bondir
washington et puis au sel des
manifestations et puis aussi les
rendez compte le pays de la liberté des
droits de l'homme qui fait un plongeon
glacial dans l'est dans les temps
anciens et gomme d'un trail et les
avancées qu'a lecture était si
difficilement acquise par an par les
femmes et en plus si on regarde les
énormes fracture qui oppose tous les
états américains on peut se dire que
objectivement au moins très états sur 50
pourrait carrément interdire
l'avortement c'est la raison pour
laquelle joe biden aujourd'hui en a fait
un cheval un cheval de bataille et a
demandé on a fait l'enjeu des élections
de la mi mandat et demandent que les
américains qu'ils aillent voter pour
soutenir le droit de l'avortement dans
les urnes alors qu'est ce que ça dit ce
scandale on peut être par lettre condal
alors de l'amérique d'aujourd'hui oui
vous faites plus il nous révèle à quel
point les états unis sont vraiment
divisé fracturée et dans certains états
dans certaines villes il ya ceux qui
défendent le walkie sme et la cancel
culture la défense des dents c'est dans
ces villes les libertés et la défense
des droits individuels sont poussés à de
tels extrêmes qu'en fait ce ils se ils
en viennent à limiter la liberté de ceux
qui représentaient l'ancien ordre
les mâles bhl ce qu'on appelait les
mâles blancs dominé en autorise de cette
fracture pour les non laurie c'est l'un
des montants et elle est rapide chic et
vous avez désormais des nombreuses
femmes ce que d'aider des états qui sont
en train de remettre en cause que de
nombreuses femmes considèrent comme un
droit absolument fondamental est qu'ils
foulée aux pieds par la volonté de la
cour suprême alors cette amérique elle a
l'air aujourd'hui au bord de la rupture
et on peut se dire qu'elle se prépare
des jours assez difficile surtout
surtout myriam si donald trump revient
au pouvoir il ya des lutteurs mois qui
arrivent important 1024 2024 ou vous
regarder évidemment j'imagine renaud
dély ces espèces de tension mais on voit
que se nourrissent l'un l'autre en fait
c'est bon
comment dire je confins d'une vraie
hystérie identitaire et on voit que les
deux en fait les dérives de ce qu'on
appelle le oak hills mais des franges
les plus radicales ou de là quand cette
culture et le tropisme l'hystérie
identitaire du tropisme en fait les deux
se nourrissent l'un l'autre et on voit
aussi que c'est pas parce que donald
trump n'est plus à la maison blanche
qu'il est des gars du 30/10 ne continue
pas de se faire sentir de façon profonde
au sein des sud-américaines et au delà
d'ailleurs dans un grand nombre de
sociétés occidentales dans la
dégradation du public le tropisme est
vraiment quelque chose qui a été à la
fois aussi un symptôme je pense
d'ailleurs des dysfonctionnement
démocratique antérieure et il n'a fait
qu'appuyer qu'attiser ses plaies et les
travailleuses mais toujours la même
femme vous pensez que donald trump a
regagné la maison d'emile terne qui sont
extrêmement importantes et puis au delà
même en tout cas sa présence est ce que
si c'est pas lui est ce qu'il ya des
descendants des héritiers ont souvient
d'ailleurs qu'avant trump y avait eu des
mouvements aux états elle était partie
multi parti qui est en quelque sorte
l'ancêtre aussi du tropisme sur certains
points merci beaucoup aux enfers est là
merci c'était passionnant merci beaucoup
les affranchis anatomie d'une trahison
la gauche contre le progrès renaud dély
édition de l'observatoire c'est la fin
de cette émission merci de nous avoir
suivis tout de suite votre soirée
documentaire gorbatchev reggane duel au
sommet un film d'antoine vitkine plus
que jamais d'actualité au à l'heure où
l'on s'interroge sur le retour de la
guerre froide en europe très belle
soirée à demain
[Musique]